as light goes into your eye it first
goes through your cornea the protective
outer surface of the eye and then it
hits your iris which is the colored part
of your eye the lens focuses the image
to the back of the retina and the retina
tissue is where the photoreceptor layers
are to detect the light impulses and
send them through the optic nerve back
to the brain our eyes are unique and
different and everybody has a unique
iris coloration like a fingerprint on
their eye and so our perception is
unique our eyes allow us to see the good
in the world it turns out that
recognizing things is a really tough
computational problem and it costs a lot
of neurons to do it so do we see
goodness when we're judging goodness I
think typically that's a beauty judgment
Spanish philosopher George Santayana
defined beauty as the pleasure we
attribute to the object these individual
differences on what we find beautiful
are a very powerful and common feature
of our lives and this can apply in quite
abstract ways that it's not just
literally what the motion is but what it
signifies
okay come forward
[Music]
squinty eyes a little bit good the most
beautiful thing that you see in a person
is the beauty in their eyes you can see
their past their presence and where they
are right at this moment through the
eyes so I did the first two years of my
modeling career and you know totally in
a blur because I wasn't saying well and
when I got my contacts and glasses I
mean the whole world just opened up it
was just like amazing like this is the
world this is what I've been missing
eyes were critical in order to see the
world and perceive the good in the world
and so our perception is unique and
allows us to be beautiful in our own way
as well as experience the beautiful
colors in the world around us when you
see good deeds you just have that
compassion feeling in your eyes and
there's the warmth and a feeling like
that overtakes you that's great
[Music]
you